أجنبية
منذ قرون استخدم العالم العربي
النجوم للملاحة ولذلك
أطلق على بعضها أسماء ذات أصل عربي
مثل الدر باران الذي يعني
التابع والعقرب الذي يعني
العقرب واليوم المنطقة
تجدد طموحاتها وتستثمر في
الاستكشاف نحو العالم.  لقد
لاحظنا على مدار السنوات الخمس الماضية
تجديدًا مذهلاً
وإعادة التأكيد على أهمية
قطاع الفضاء خاصة من
حكومتي المملكة العربية السعودية والإمارات العربية المتحدة اللتين
أطلقتا استراتيجياتهما الوطنية للفضاء
بطريقة متسارعة، ونعتقد أن
هناك تقدمًا  أن نكون سباقًا حقيقيًا للحصول على
المال عندما يتعلق الأمر بمكانة
برامج الفضاء
للاعبينا الإقليميين فيما يتعلق
بنظراء شركة الاستشارات العالمية ماكنزي،
يمكن أن تصل قيمة صناعة الفضاء إلى
تريليون دولار بحلول عام 2030، وهذا من
447 مليار دولار اليوم  تشير
صناعة ضخمة ترغب المنطقة في
الاستفادة منها إلى معلوماتنا السوقية إلى
أن حجم سوق قطاع الفضاء الإقليمي
يبلغ حوالي 10 مليارات دولار
اليوم،
ومن المتوقع أن ينمو
بمعدل مثير للإعجاب يبلغ حوالي 22 بالمائة
ليصل إلى حوالي 40 مليار دولار بحلول عام
2030.  ومن
الأمثلة على ذلك ما شهدته سلطنة عمان
مؤخراً من إعلان عن إنشاء
أول ميناء فضائي في المنطقة والذي سيكون
مقره استراتيجياً في
مدينة دنكان الرياضية بالسلطنة بالقرب من
خط استواء الأرض. وهناك لاعب آخر في
المنطقة هو دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة بقطاع فضائي يزيد عن 860
مليون دولار.  لقد أرسلوا
أول رائد فضاء إلى الفضاء في عام 2019.
بدأنا هذا المسعى معًا في عام
2017. لقد تم اختيارنا في عام 2019،
قضيت سبعة أيام على متن
محطة الفضاء الدولية والتي تم
تصنيفها كأول مهمة لدولة
الإمارات العربية المتحدة الآن  تمتلك العديد من
الأقمار الصناعية ونجحت في نشر مسبار مارزو الخاص بها
في عام 2021 والذي لا يزال
يدور حول الكوكب ويدرسه. وقد
أعلنوا مؤخرًا عن مهمة جديدة
لإرسال واستكشاف مركبة إلى
حزام الكويكبات بحلول عام 2028 بحثًا عن أدلة حول
أصل الحياة.
وقتًا مثيرًا للاهتمام، وهنا في
الأسواق الحضرية المتحدة، نحن ملتزمون بالمشاركة
وأن نكون لاعبًا نشطًا للغاية
فيما يتعلق بقطاع الضوء والفضاء القائم على البشر
بشكل عام،
وهو واحد من ستة عرب يمثلون
المنطقة في السفر إلى الفضاء،
وتوقعت بعد ذلك أن يكون ذلك أ  رحلة
في عام 2019 سنرى دولًا أخرى
من المنطقة تشارك
وتبدأ برنامج رحلات الفضاء البشرية الخاص بها وهذا
ما حدث في مايو من
هذا العام شاهدت هازل المملكة العربية السعودية
مهمة فضائية مثيرة M2 بما في ذلك
أول رائدة فضاء عربية ريانا
برناوي